[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror my little book review show
the book that i chose this week this was
a completely and utterly random pick
basically i was kind of like well i've
sort of run out of most of the print
books that i was going to read and i
thought to myself well i should probably
take advantage of this kindle unlimited
thing
you know i have read a few books on
there but honestly i usually read like
non-fiction on there like getting ready
for the regular uh podcast episodes and
stuff i don't read a lot of fiction on
there so i kind of feel like maybe in
the next year i should kind of maybe
start doing that what i did was i just
kind of did a search and because
for the month of december i basically
wanted to do sort of winter themed kind
of stuff as much as possible i don't
know how that's gonna play out actually
because i haven't played at that part
that far in advance but uh you know so
while i was looking through i said
basically my only uh stipulation was i
wanted something that was sort of like
winter based or winter themed and
something that was very highly rated and
something that was available to read for
free with kindle unlimited so the book
that i came across was a little book
called autumn bleeds into winter by jeff
strand so uh actually so i don't
obviously have like a print version to
show you because i read the ebook
but uh i'll put the i'll put the cover
of it like right here in the video
somewhere you know so you can see it
this side that side i just i don't know
which side i still haven't figured that
out uh so i didn't really know anything
about this author when i went into this
book like i said basically it just had
all the stipulations it was available on
kindle unlimited it was really really
highly rated had like four and a half to
five stars on goodreads uh or on amazon
which i think is the same thing and uh
it kind of had like the name and the
word winter in the title so it's just
kind of like all right bob's your uncle
that's what we're gonna do and this book
ended up being awesome i it was so so
good this was another one of those books
that
you know how every like every now and
then you just kind of come across a book
and this kind of happened to me a little
bit with uh enamorata too which i
reviewed a couple weeks back that i
talked about that i just bought at
random
this kind of this kind of happened with
this one too where it's kind of like you
just start reading it and like from the
first paragraph i was just completely
sucked in and it's like every moment
that i had to do something else and
couldn't keep reading the book i was
like angry because i just wanted it's
just such a great like fast-paced
action-packed
story and it's just it's very
straightforward it's very simple
but
it's just so well done and it's just so
entertaining that i just kept finding
myself just like man i really really
need to get back to that so i read it
like almost
almost in one sitting but i couldn't do
it because
other things intervened but i did end up
reading it i think it took me like two
sittings because i read like more than
half of it just like in one setting so
i'm like man this is so good you know
and then i had to go do something else
and then like it took me a couple more
tries to finish it but
it's just really really good now when i
was researching this though this book
came out in 2020 by the way so it's
fairly recent
when i was researching jeff strand
apparently see this is how out of the
[ __ ] loop i am and this is why i
really need to get back into the kindle
unlimited thing and read some newer [ __ ]
um you know i'm still gonna read old
[ __ ] too because obviously i like that
too
but i just feel like so much good [ __ ]
is being published nowadays and i'm just
kind of like missing out on it uh you
know so hopefully there's like a lot of
more new stuff on kindle unlimited
that's really worth reading because i
really want to get into that in the new
year
so what i had failed to realize was that
jeff strand the author of this book is
has written you guys
i was like on his amazon author page and
i was like counting all the books and
then i got tired of counting it's like
he wrote so many now
he usually gets kind of lumped in with
uh with horror but uh apparently this is
the first one book of his that i've read
so i can't really say it but according
to what a lot of his other fans said and
like some of the reviews said he usually
writes it's somewhere in the vein of
horror but he writes all kind of
different things and they said his thing
is kind of like more
i don't want to say like horror comedy
more like funny stuff like funny parody
like sarcastic kind of uh humor this
book has humor in it too but
it's kind of like not
a lot of the reviews that that it was
still great but it was like not the same
kind of humor it's not the same level of
humor because there's like usually
stuff's like really really funny and
this is really funny too but it's also
like kind of serious i don't know if i'd
call it serious necessarily did you guys
see the movie
summer of 84. i'm pretty sure it's a
shutter original or a shutter exclusive
this book
kind of reminded me of that although
honestly i like this book better and i
liked that movie a lot i'm not saying
that but if you saw that movie you'll
get an idea kind of like the vibe that
i'm talking about because this kind of
reminded me of that and i'm like
actually not the person that thought
that because i saw a couple other
reviews that pointed out that similar
it's not
similar similar but just kind of the
tone of it is similar so you know so you
know kind of what you're getting into
but yeah so the guy's written
so many books and like i said usually
funny stuff um usually real gory uh i
love that his that his author page like
his biography
says a four-time nominee and zero time
winner but come on he lost to stephen
king twice
of the bram stoker award
uh and also he won the splatterpunk
award uh and apparently a bunch of his
novels are also in negotiations to be
made into films so
we'll see how that goes and i'm so i'm
just like amazed that somebody that
prolific
and somebody whose work seems to be that
well regarded particularly like by the
horror community that i hadn't really
heard of him before like i said that's
no ding on him because it's like i you
know
i'm kind of like out of it in the sense
that you try to keep up but with the
advent of like self-publishing you know
too
there's just so much [ __ ] being
published nowadays and like a lot of it
you know yeah probably a lot of it sucks
and it's not worth reading but it's like
a lot of it's really really good too i
mean so
i kind of feel like i'll never live long
enough to read all this stuff and it
kind of makes me sad but at least i
stumbled across this one like finally uh
you know just completely at random and
ended up really really enjoying it a lot
so because this book is fairly recent
and it's fairly
straightforward i don't want to spoil
too much about it but i'll kind of like
give you a little bit of where it's
going
so it's set in
1979 in fairbanks alaska
and uh the setup of it is that it's a
guy who you're led to believe is in the
present day and he's writing about
something that happened to him back in
1979 when he was 14 years old
so what happens very near the beginning
of the story is that this kid curtis
black who's kind of like a chubby he's
not like a social outcast exactly but
he's not like super popular he's just
kind of one of those kids that fades
into the background he's a little bit of
a troublemaker but not enough to like
get draw attention or anything like that
so he's this chubby 14 year old not all
that athletic and uh you know kind of a
cut up but not you know not overtly
so uh he has a best friend like they
kind of he kind of goes a little bit
into like how he met his best friend
whose name is todd um they don't spend a
lot of time on that but they just he
just kind of like sets up
how they met how their friendship got
established and how like over this one
summer they just like hung out all the
time and how they sort of became
inseparable like i think todd like moved
a couple doors down from him or onto the
same street or whatever because he had
moved from someplace else so one night
uh they were having a sleepover and todd
got angry
uh they had some kind of fight about i
guess curtis like said something
said something sideways about his mom
and uh he wouldn't take it as a joke he
got mad and he decided he was gonna walk
home all by himself
in the middle of the night like in the
freezing cold
so he proceeds to do that
and curtis
after a few minutes he starts to feel
kind of bad and he's like well okay well
i better go after him and you know see
what's what now the funny thing is that
he's not going after him to like
apologize necessarily or even like check
to see if he's okay
he actually puts on like a mouse mask
that he had like left over from a long
ago halloween or something i think he
described it as like some kind of like
off thing like mickey mouse it wasn't a
mickey mouse mask but it was like a you
know a dollar general version
so he had one and he's like i'm gonna
like sneak up behind him i'm gonna sneak
around in the woods like where i know
he's gonna be walking and i'm gonna jump
out and scare him so like i said 14 year
old boy you know [ __ ] so like jeff
strand like the way he puts it across
because i have a couple i have uh two
younger brothers in case you guys don't
know so i'm very familiar with how
without 14 year old boys like acted so
it's kind of like uh so yeah so he's
doesn't care he doesn't want to
apologize he just wants to go like jump
out of the woods and scare him however
what ends up happening is that curtis
goes out in the mask and he hides in the
woods and he sees todd walking home
and then he sees this silver car pull up
next to todd
and it looks like todd like freaks out
like it starts crying and then gets into
the car with this person
uh and it's a car that curtis does not
recognize
although he kind of starts going over
there and like like looking and he's
like but he recognizes the dude he
doesn't know like he doesn't know him
know him but he knows that he lives like
a couple of blocks away like he's seen
him like in the yard before so he does
uh and i think he kind of and he knows
his name as well
so basically he sees his best friend get
in the car with this dude who neither of
them know
and then lee and then leave now it
should be noted too that prior to this a
couple of other kids have gone missing
in fairbanks so it's kind of like a big
thing that's going on at the time
so obviously curtis is like okay well
todd just got kidnapped by the person
that's been doing all this and i know
who the dude is like i know what his
name is and i know vaguely where he
lives
so curtis does exactly the right thing
he goes to the cops and the cops uh
actually do believe him um you know he's
like i saw the dude's face i've seen him
before he's like i don't know exactly
where he lives but i know what what
street he lives on and i know what his
name is uh so he tells the cops that and
the cops go and investigate
but uh unfortunately they don't find
enough evidence and they also don't find
the silver car that he saw uh so they
don't have they don't find enough
evidence to like um you know to arrest
the dude whose name is gerald martin
so after this happens and todd never
comes back curtis decides because i
think he feels like it's this isn't you
know this is all from his point of view
with the upshot of it being that he's
now a grown person like talking about
what happened to him back when he was
14. but he also like gets back into the
14 year old mindset so basically he
decides well because it's kind of like
my fault that he got kidnapped because
if we hadn't had that fight he would
have just stayed over my house and
everything would have been fine you know
he had we had that fight he stormed off
and then he got kidnapped and now he's
gone
and so i guess because he feels guilty
about that
and the police don't have enough
evidence to do anything curtis decides
even though as i said he is a chubby 14
year old kid
he decides that he's going to go
confront gerald martin himself
and try to elicit a confession out of
him
now as i said the first paragraph
that sucked me into this so like i said
this isn't really a spoiler because this
is pretty much the first paragraph the
first paragraph
is this kid
who has stolen 300
out of his dad's safe
uh in cash and is going to this like
sleazy dude in a van to buy a gun okay
like a 14 year old kid in 1979 and
that's what he's going to use so like i
said this is like the first page that's
what he's going to use to go confront
this suspected serial killer serial
kidnapper
and he's going to get a confession out
of him and find out what happened to his
best friend obviously things don't go
quite the way he planned
um
and uh to a degree where
you seriously you know because it's
being written
from the present day like this is
something that happened when i was 14
years old so you know that he's not
gonna die
but the [ __ ] that happens to this poor
kid and like i said it's not just him
like other people start getting involved
too because he meets this girl at school
and she's like super into this she's
he's like she's like the first person
her name is tina and she's like the
first person that he tells the absolute
truth to because he does of course does
not tell his parents that he went over
to the suspected serial killer's house
and like held a gun on him and like try
to get him to confess
um yeah so he didn't tell him that but
he told tina that tina gets really
excited about it and wants to get
involved uh so you know so there are
other people involved it's like not just
her but like his parents her dad
like all this other kind of stuff so all
these people get involved as the stakes
start getting higher and higher and
escalating and escalating and it's kind
of like i kind of felt myself like you
know a few times i'm just kind of like
well that seems like a little outlandish
or out there but it's like now that i'm
thinking about it i don't think it
really would be because like i said a 14
year old boy isn't the brightest
crayon in the box
and i kind and you so you can kind of
see where he was coming from like he
felt so bad that his best friend had
disappeared and was probably dead
because of him at least what he
perceived and because the cops didn't
have enough evidence to do anything and
he was so certain that that was the dude
that he saw uh that he was gonna like
resolve this and avenge todd and so it
gets to a point where just he just gets
in deeper and deeper and deeper because
like i said he's a 14 year old kid and
he's basically facing off against
a serial killer as well as like other
things going on too
which i don't really want to spoil
because like i said this poor kid it's
like you you understand where he's
coming from and he's such a great
character like his
uh the the narrative voice is just so
entertaining i think that was kind of
like what sucked me in like i said it's
a very straightforward story but it's
one of those stories where you know
shit's really bad at the beginning and
then it just gets worse and worse and
worse and worse and you're just like oh
my god like how much worse could this
[ __ ] get like for this poor kid and
it just keeps happening and it's just it
was so so great i had such a good time
with this book it's like i said it's
almost kind of like and it's actually
even listed on the amazon page it's
actually listed as a coming of age story
which it actually kind of is
um and he even says like in the present
day he even says at the end like at the
end of his quote-unquote memoir
that you know i guess this was like the
story of you know my first love because
you know he's talking about tina the
girl that he met and and all this other
stuff and how he like kind of how he
like found his confidence uh you know
and things like that so it's a it's kind
of a coming-of-age story it's funny
not like
i don't it's like it's funny but i guess
it's not funny in the same way that some
of his other stuff is like i said that's
just from reading like a cursory uh
thing of some of the other reviews
because i haven't read any of his other
stuff but apparently some of his other
stuff is like way funnier like way more
over the top funny whereas this one is
just like
situationally funny and the way the kid
like the narrative voice of the kid like
talking about what's happening that's
also funny because he's kind of like
this smart assy like 14 year old and so
that's actually funny but it's actually
like a pretty
it's a pretty [ __ ] up like some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens in it but it's
just this like i said this was just a
fun
entertaining 14 year old kid versus
serial killer type of story so like i
said that's why it kind of reminded me a
little bit of summer of 84 because i
think in that it's been a while since
i've seen it but i think in that that
was kind of like the like a serial
killer or pedophile or something like
that i think it was a serial killer
wasn't it like moved into their
neighborhood and like or they thought he
was a serial killer i can't even
remember what happened in the end of it
but it's a similar kind of vibe to that
where it's not like a comedy overtly but
it's just kind of funny like from the
situations and like i said you're just
horrified at all the terrible things
that are happening around this poor kid
but yeah so if any of you guys have read
any of other of jeff strand's stuff and
can recommend anything to me because
he's read he's written so many and it's
like after reading this one and i really
really enjoyed it a lot i was just kind
of like well i'm gonna have to read some
more of his stuff but i don't really
know where to start because he's written
so many so many books and i'm just kind
of like okay well eventually i have to
get around to it so if any of you guys
have read any of his stuff and can
recommend any to me i would really like
appreciate it also if any of you have
read this one autumn bleeds into winter
please let me know what you thought of
it if you thought it was fun as well as
i said earlier um you know probably he
gets like a more more royalties if you
buy the paperback or whatever but if you
have kindle unlimited already
you can actually read it on kindle
unlimited for free which is what i did
so uh check it out if you if it sounds
like something that you would like and i
will see you guys on the next homes of
terror bye